Gonna go to bed. Last night,
I could not stop thinking about a matcha that had a Poppy in it.
I don't know why, but I couldn't stop thinking about it.
And then it LED me to TikTok,
and I was like, has anyone tried this?
Has anyone done this? And a few people have,
but I haven't. And so the fact that other people have tried it
and they had a good experience made me feel good about trying it.
So we're going to do a strawberry,
lemon, Poppy with some matcha in it today. Let's give it a go.
Not much.
Let's mix it up and give it a try.
I can taste the matcha. It's really good.
This would be, like a perfect summery drink.
I think that it's also missing a little something.
I think I might add a little maple syrup.
That's really good.
Okay.
I think I wanna try it with,
like, a.
I got orange cream. I think the orange cream would be really good,
but I'm not mad about this.
Out of 10, I give it a seven and a half.
I love trying new things with matcha.
So, so fun.